[Music]
here's a really good one for steve to
comment on so you know the graphics card
company nvidia well they make a lot more
than graphics cards but in video oh yes
they refined
5.5 million by the sec
for failing to acknowledge that crypto
mining was responsible for their massive
profit increase wait what
everyone knows that i know what i know
you'll see gamers know that everybody
you need you need graphics cards to have
miners and stuff well it depends on what
you're mining but usually yeah like
ethereum miners and anything where
you're mining complex hashes yeah yeah
definitely one you definitely want gpus
so back in the like in 2017 when you
couldn't even buy a graphics card to
save your life if you were just putting
in a computer uh it was very very
obvious right
that everybody was buying them up for
crypto even at the store everyone there
knows everyone there is my billy miners
it's like you're all talking shop about
miners nobody's there to [ __ ] pz game
yeah
but the reason why they were supposed to
make a uh they were supposed to make
that an actual
official announcement in their
statistics that like oh we made more
money because people are buying um
graphics cards from miners they didn't
do that because if you say something
like that
then your investors who see this huge
hike
you're not you don't want them to know
it's because of crypto because a lot of
them view crypto as volatile so they
won't think that's how it's always going
to be
so if they go wow there's a 54 increase
in in profits great nvidia must be doing
something right keep it up but if you
say oh it's because of crypto everyone's
buying these graphics cards they're
going to go oh after this year i'm going
to pull all my money out because the
year after that when crypto the fad dies
out nobody's gonna be buying these cards
yeah fat dies every every couple years
guys and they're supposed to tell their
investors that's exactly why they didn't
do that so now they got fined 5.5
million [ __ ] i feel like that's nothing
to a accompany that size just about to
tell you what do you think
what do you think the revenue is they
probably made nine figures they were
killing i mean dude you couldn't get
graphics card to save your life like it
was like crazy dude like for how many
years is this for this is their 2018
filing oh 2018. they're only getting
it's news now because now they're being
they're being uh penalized for it but i
thought crypto was dead in 2018. that's
like it's got to be in the
previous year probably 100 million
okay so imagine this you just got fined
by five million yeah
for something that happened
that gave you revenue of
9.714 billion
billions with a b business is good
dude that's like when um remember when
that's less than tax way less than time
apple was killing everybody and then
samsung's like [ __ ] it we're copying
apple to save our business they did that
and then like you know what [ __ ] it
we'll pay the fine later and that's
exactly what they did i did it in
pennies pennies a billion dollars or
whatever wow
so
but they saved their business big time
and they actually have a huge market
share because of it nine billion nine
point seven one four billion i'm so off
i thought it would be just like 100
million but at the same time though it's
like they're just paying the sec in a
fine right it's not like uh that's money
or percentage that goes back to
investors or shareholders that maybe may
have gotten affected if like sales
didn't work out you know what i'm saying
yeah just goes to the securities
commission anyway it's so [ __ ] yeah
it goes through the sc what do they do
with it yeah it's an educated decision
for them to choose not to tell investors
that yeah yeah
and it was honestly what makes that the
wrong choice in any of these statistics
i wonder what the rule is for disclosure
and like why you have to tell them and
whatever if you get information that's
the rule is because you're it's
misleading the investors it's telling
them that you're making profit on just
business as usual rather than like
something that they will view as an
anomaly but if an investor asks and says
why the profits and if they don't
disclose it that's a penalty yeah
exactly if they're just like hey
huge but it is if no one asks is that
supposed to still be disclosed oh they
they definitely asked but you know in
this situation they live not every
investor is going to have the freaking
time or whatever to just get in there
and ask like so many people got money
spread out everywhere i'm surprised they
didn't like do one of those things where
it's like oh we had a killer year we did
this we did this we did this we did this
we sold the crypto we did this we did
you know what i'm saying where they they
mention it in order to legally like not
face like potential ramifications
but if you're gonna make 9 billion and
then you know the fine might be like
five million because it's a very [ __ ]
can't wait till they admit that they've
been running bitcoin or um ethereum
miners for years yeah a garen [ __ ] and
that's one of their assets guarantee it
guarantees that's the the main thing is
not that they never said it verbally
they probably have a million times
you're just supposed to file a very
specific form with that information on
it and they didn't do that
it doesn't matter what they say they
could say that it's that it's freaking
uh the prices have gone up because of
tethered to rice you guys get those uh
letters from the things that you're
invested into and they're like we're
gonna vote on this committee and i'm all
like i only got like a thousand dollars
in here i don't know that vote's gonna i
got one for endeavor because i
i put a hundred dollars in it like two
years ago that's the company that owns
the ufc oh and i wow i bought it like a
hundred dollars of it and they sent me
an email today they're like oh we're
gonna vote on the shareholdings and i
was like [ __ ] i want a hundred dollars
which is worth 88 dollars today
so your boy is gonna have a say and this
is a huge company it's not much
different honestly endows like
decentralized autonomous organizations
and crypto like how many times do you
see people voting on that [ __ ] like you
see like if you had 100 of people voting
it'd be much different but you see like
[ __ ] 30 maybe 50 or less much less or
if it's 30 it's because like three
whales own 30 percent
you know what i mean or because maybe
the it's like one of the hot button
issues and not one of the normal issues
like something that's when a lot of
voters come in yeah i voted on a few but
most of them they pass without me even
knowing that it's there yeah
yeah we usually only jump in to vote
when there's like a threat to something
that affects us negatively but if i'm
like a shareholder of nvidia and they
didn't tell me that like shit's you know
that what whatever they're doing but i'm
just seeing the [ __ ]
you know price increase i don't give a
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying right
so cool to say you have a shareholders
meeting yeah i'm attending one sounds
good no big deal
i mean those things look like meanings
i put on my google calendar and i'm like
yeah so yeah that 5.5 million is .05
of that revenue wow
oh that's uh that's what we usually get
from our our banks for our savings
accounts
in interest point zero five so then
paying that penalty it also exonerates
them from being able to uh admit or deny
the findings they don't have to say [ __ ]
they're like okay we'll pay it we're not
gonna admit we did anything wrong we're
not gonna you know
we're not gonna deny nothing i mean
they're just playing the game that's the
game they're playing the game those are
the rules that were set in place
all good nvidia stock would have been
pretty good for sure let's see if we
have no idea
is it too late to the game for sure
see these are the things that i don't
that i wish i knew that i spent more
time on but i'm watching people farm on
youtube
farm what just
people like hey i bought a farm in the
midwest and i'm pursuing my dreams to be
a farmer and then they're like look at
this year's harvest we got [ __ ]
chicken rotating but on the ground is
that a fantasy of yours like owning a
farm i like farms yeah i mean like i'm a
you know i got a partnership 12 but like
i never visited [ __ ]
are you supposed to nah i mean i do the
online marketing portion of it so like
yeah it's like it doesn't matter that
you walk through it looking at all the
vlogs and [ __ ] i might have bought this
this is okay so up 40 up 30 last year we
could do better but
i like
i was probably too busy watching mascot
abuse videos on youtube
what's mascot abuse [ __ ] a mascot
suit people anytime mascots are getting
[ __ ] up [ __ ] makes me laugh
oh just
just a team mascot but like it's either
either he's wailing on somebody else or
somebody else is wailing on him i
[ __ ] see him while like the giant
furry head's still on yes yes oh he
plugs into the head literal
mascot abuse videos that [ __ ] die
every time i love it you want to know
something really yeah you want to know
something kind of sad
so this article you used to beat up one
and then they died
i just think steve will have something
really nice to say about this so this
article um
i chose to use a
uh article from kotaku which kind of is
it's like more of like a video game
culture article these guys [ __ ] hate
crypto you know what you know what you
want to last line of this article it
says crypto [ __ ] everything up for
everyone since 2009. dude you know why
are they gamers that haters why they
can't get the graphics cards they're so
[ __ ] pissed
i get why at least i get that but it's
not just like well i didn't buy it so
[ __ ] them yeah they also don't like
crypto and nfts because it's kind of
like invasive into like what is supposed
to be like a growing gaming space trying
to
his face just getting more and more
softer out of all the people that would
be into crypto i would think it would be
gamers because it's like the computer
world it will be why are they because
they hate it more than wall street what
they should because crypto gaming sucks
dick right yeah that's why that's the
reason why wait what's what's considered
crypto gaming oh bro
bad games with monetary gains it's like
2d barely spreading like looks like [ __ ]
is that is that like the awkwardness
no oculus is tight looking yeah because
a lot of people that's not considered
crypto gaming no
wait which unless there's a crypto game
on oculus i haven't heard of oh i i just
don't know i'm talking about like the
popular ones like axi infinity and like
all these other ones i just don't know
anything to have a like a conversation
with you about this so i'm gonna shut up
thank you no you're fine that ends the
video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you